good friend Brian Urlacher back here on
the program how are you Brian I'm doing
very very I'm doing fine what do you
think it true Biscay last night
what'd you think of that I was exciting
to watch I'm all exactly did they you
know kind of waited to put it on this
long and Susan give them I'll get some
time to watch Clinton or just kind of
take it and what then I was like but I
was happy for I'm it's exciting to be
embarrassing right now because I think
you see what he can do you know give him
a couple of weapons you know some
receivers get those guys healthy but
their offensive lines you know they got
good running backs future looks bright
for him so you think he looked ready did
he look ready to you know Brian what
they were they were very basic with what
they did you know a lot of boots on
outside zone place with the running
backs up the boots but you know you see
the athletic ability you can see his arm
strength you see you know he he fits in
and he fits the mold of a quarterback my
opinion and so I just wonder what John
Fox is thinking today what do you think
he's thinking today Brian my magazine
lost number one but they're really good
defense you know they've been up there a
couple years now at the top of the
league in defensive stats but I never
happy until they win but I think he's
got the little encouraged with the way
the kids played and you know I had the
bad turn over there at the end but I
wasn't here specifically I was a nice
play by him know I know that when I
guess I'm aiming at here I'm driving at
Brian is I don't know if he's got that
if he was saying a year one attached at
the hip with this kid then I would say
that he could take that opinion but he
he needs to win football games now right
I mean unless their point unless they're
willing to let him grow with the
quarterback after already having a
couple of substandard don't sound he was
talk with color you have a choice with
that because they paid him before talks
got there it was kind of stuck with him
for a year didn't have a choice in that
and maybe they're thinking okay we're
gonna have to do on quarterback and you
know the the world in three was they
want to take your safety but the Bears
ownership said take too risky and number
two trade up and get them that's just
the world mystery I'm not sure if that's
true or not so maybe I don't think we
got to give coach talks couple years
with this kid and see what happens you
know it's you guys quarterback dad I got
that high with the coaches third year
you know there's gonna be some growing
pains and he's gonna be a couple years
to kind of
to get into the system I would think
they're gonna get in couple more years
I hope wait no Fox you think I gotta win
right now but they almost won the game
last night
stop saying they can't win what you're
risky right now is good enough to win
yeah because you would advocate for Fox
sticking around Brian right 20 percent
I'm a huge fan of coach Fox you know
he's won everywhere he's been it's been
a struggle in Chicago so far I do
believe the defense is one of the better
ones in the NFL and they just had
problems with the quarterback position
and keeping players healthy the heavily
receiver they get gets hurt it's
frustrating Brian Urlacher joining me
here on the Rich Eisen show did you
agree with the suspension for Trevathan
on that hit on Davante Adams did you
agree with that prime yes and no how
about that it was it was a very violent
hit I don't think he was trying to be
malicious I think you have to look at
intent most of the time I host plays I
don't think he was trying to hurt the
guy football is a full speed sport in
the any plays at full speed you know I
hit the guy he's trying to get a shot on
him before he goes down the whistle hi
Paul that was a targeting honey percent
should have been fine yeah I just don't
know if I grew the suspensions you know
I the other day I was watching a college
football game and I should not stay in
the rule in college where they eject the
guy for the rest of that game and if
it's the first half you know but the
second half the first half the next game
chinese-made crazy
you know they they review it no I saw
but I just don't think it should be
checked you guys after one you know
so-called target well the problem with
that is that I have with that Brian is
that when you rely on replay to review
indent that's impossible you cannot do
that because when you look at replay you
can see well did did one centimeter of
his helmet
connect with a half a centimeter of what
is considered the head chest and neck
area right I mean yeah for sure no no
that to me is I'm with you on that on
targeting yes the officials picked up a
flag they threw I'm sorry my dogs are
parking in the back yard gonna call
crazy this will come they picked up the
flag on Sunday ho for a hit that they
thought was targeting and they said
nobody hit him in the chest you know I
was like you never see that NSI you
never seen a pickup flags for
she wouldn't they throw you know I told
to throw the flags it looks malicious or
bad till the flag and actually picked it
up and got it right because it wasn't
you could see on the replay you hit him
in the chest
yeah shoulder that's a legal hit I was
excited to see to do that um for a
change I don't know if you saw a most
Brian Urlacher here in the Rich Eisen
show know if you watch the Packers
Cowboys game Brian but the Blake part
don't watch many games anymore but I did
watch down ok so Blake Martinez his army
here des in the top of the head in the
end zone
and that was flagged for 15 yards do you
think those should be reviewable no I I
do the one thing I do like about the
college was a d'hubert do him I don't
like the end result when they check the
players but I do like if they can review
him I think that would have been big
doubles long I think most people agree
with that because it wasn't malicious
you know he's going for the bar he's
football happens so fast it's hard to
adjust your angle on some of those plays
and I think that was a terrible call our
people and the way you can tell is that
the NFL doesn't find these guys for the
hits because they go over every single
hit this almost penalty to Charles a
flag in the game and you define where
they don't that would not only go get
fined Brian Urlacher all-pro linebacker
for so many years eight-time Pro Bowl or
College Football Hall of Famer joining
me here on the Rich Eisen show as always
when you come on the show there's two
things that we hit you know that right
there's always one or two or five oh
okay so the other one is Cutler you you
mentioned him did you see him did you
see him execute the Wildcat in London
did you see that Brian hood out there he
stood out there while they were running
the Wildcat he didn't budge he didn't
move an inch
hands on usually tells guys to go out
there and do not get hurt uncle triumphs
lots of fun don't run around just go out
there and maybe you take a guy out of
the box and he he said he executed it
perfectly he didn't move he kept his
hands and since the whole time did he
get here did he run around no
he didn't do anything that's a
successful play in the West you're gonna
want to walk you through my self defense
we're not gonna throw it to our core
unless you throw it to him in the past
yes he's out of the place so you know
good job okay Chris Brockman headline
Rich Eisen show headline Brian Urlacher
defends Jay Jay Cutler's love of the
game oh and execution execution of to
perfection again alright Brian Urlacher
mister restore himself
take a listen I was on Dan Patrick show
last week I appeared in person I guess
Charles Barkley was watching it and he
calls in to Dan show and says this to
Dan and after I left give it give a
listen I mean one more favor from you
okay got a hurry tell Rich Eisen it's
time to come on home shaving them here
[Music]
to come on home is over he lost the
other yeah you may have to either go see
restore or just gonna go ball with him
and that's you know I was holding on for
a long time I just decided to go bald
and I decided to go back with it so so
and Dion Dion is well did you notice I'm
on the team that they've got the
hairline go now he's trying to grow it
out it looks well it's pretty good okay
now we did we send this to a poll
question we did okay to our sisters so
last week Brian we threw up a Twitter
poll what should rich do with this hair
situation here are the final results
26% keep as is now we haven't tie at 37%
bull Barkley got 37% and full Dion
Urlacher got 37% well you got decision
tomato you don't have to do is it you
know and do whatever you want how do you
feel about it rich where you clean it
well I gotta be honest with you Brian
for the first time and in quite some
time
um I'm really
getting hard about doing the Urlacher I
really mean my wife was for some reason
she's I guess you could put out sweet
house come on your show today and she
was so she googled she goes with some
pictures of you in your younger day when
you had nice hair you know she's like
Bonnie let's cook look there my wife has
a similar attitude Brian I gotta be
honest with you so just quick consult
here I mean how long how long does it
take I mean what what you'll be there
for a day's like any other procedures
would be there for one day hours what
are you talking about what eight hours
what they do they want they're very
particular where they put the hairs and
you know where they take him out where
they put him back here
they don't screw around so it takes a
little bit but you don't seem to be as
bald as maybe some of the clients in the
past okay alright now how long would it
take to like get back on the air I mean
how long do you know what come on it
wouldn't be Redwood if you'd like dotted
and all that stuff 'red you'll have a
little bit of what's the word I'm
looking for um so those boys out there
come are rich rash like a rash like it
looks like a rancher like a sunburn
maybe a little irritated how about
there's a word okay an angry I'll have
an angry page once you get down on a
Friday and go back to work on a Monday
he'll okay that we'd have to worry about
it you get a couple days to recover
you're good to go wow we can do a Friday
show on location all right Brian I'm
gonna I'm really thinking hard about I
really think there's options out there
you know if you want that option I I'm
glad I took that option because I like
the way it looks you know it took me a
while to get used to see myself bald now
I'm so used to see myself with her
asking myself all oh my
Brian come on you were such a handsome
bald man
I had a great bald shaved head I'm not
gonna disagree with that but I I do like
to hear okay all right Rich Eisen show
headline Brian Urlacher's told me I
could have a head start in by Friday
back by Monday boom I'm just saying
you're not as bad you're not as bald as
some of the clients in the past okay
you're talking to one of those clients
otherwise okay Brian oh I appreciate you
giving me the confidence you know what
baby I thought it held on longer I would
look like you do you take care of Brian
lo always love charity take care okay
there's Brian the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
help the NFL figure out what it catches